melissa is in Idaho hi Melissa welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show Dave I'm so
excited to talk to you I'm a big fan I'm
honored how can I help
well so I have a lot of life changes
coming up I am getting married in May
and thank you and I've been working for
the last couple of years I'm 23 and I
make about seventy four thousand dollars
a year good for you and I have saved
about twenty thousand dollars above my
emergency fund so I guess I'm in baby
step 3b you are but my question is so my
fiance has a little bit of school debt
it's about $12,000 right now tell you
what I'm gonna make you whole through
the break so I can hear the whole story
and give you a proper answer sorry about
that I'm a slave commercial 23 years old
getting married in May $24,000 income at
twenty thousand savings and your fiance
he's got twelve thousand of student loan
debt I would you told me before the
break yes that was you good okay good
I'm back in them Lane then good all
right so cool so your questions what my
question is he has about four more years
of school which includes graduate school
to become a physical therapist and so as
we're talking about money he wants to
pay off the debt but he thinks that
since it's not gaining any interest or
anything then we can just kind of have
that amount of money set aside in a
savings account and then pay it off once
he's fully done with school we're
planning to cashflow the rest of his
schooling good okay number one goal is
cash flow the schooling number two goal
is to become debt-free so if you have a
plan to cash flow the schooling and you
in the plan does not include using all
of the twenty thousand dollars you have
saved in order to do that then when you
get back from the honeymoon pay off his
student loan he's wrong okay he's
playing hey listen if you won't play
footsie with debt and try to figure out
some way you're gonna beat debt your
whole life you're gonna do broke your
whole lot
the best thing you can do with death
straight like a snake they all bite
they're all poisonous kill it even
little student loan debts that don't
accrue interest while I'm in PT school
now get rid of it be done with the
concept don't allow it back in your
house beat the snot out of it and that's
what I would do now so in other words
we're gonna use your fabulous income
that you have at 23 years old making
seventy five thousand dollars a year
that's awesome what do you do I am a
technical solutions consultant for a
printing company you are killing it
awesome a great income I mean and so
we're gonna use your great income and
his part-time work while he's going to
PT school and cash flow him out right
okay yeah let's do that and so when you
get back from the honeymoon pay it off
does that make sense
it does yeah yep definitely okay so can
you get him to do it I I think so um he
knows that I'm like a Dave Ramsey expert
and he hasn't really been you know he's
not been bad with money but he
definitely admires that about me so I
think I can show him this clip in
convention yeah well regardless of Dave
Ramsey you were way ahead of him I mean
so yeah he should look to you for advice
on this not to do it all for him but
we're gonna do it together but the
concepts you've been using have been
more successful than the concepts he's
been using regardless of whether you got
them from me right okay the fruit is
there I mean the fruits on the tree you
you you've got you know you've got
positive results he's got negative
results financially so I mean you just
you know this set of behaviors creates
this result the set of behaviors creates
that result I kind of like what you do
every day and really what he's gonna be
doing every day is a PT it's the same
thing behaviors create results and so
you need to decide which behaviors are
gonna engage in all that kind of jump so
hey very cool very cool